bonjour je vous invite à découvrir un
autre pont canal celui qui est situé à
châtillon sur le cher un pont qui
enjambera la solde qui vient de
romorantin
ce canal a servi à la navigation
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de bateaux
mais peut-être des vélos voire des
randonneurs en tout cas c'est un des
projets phares du pays du val de cher le
pont-canal de châtillon sur cher est le
symbole d'un savoir-faire des 19e une
prouesse technique qui accompagne que le
développement de la france industrielle
[Musique]
canal de berry qui a vraiment servi qui
a été un des grands enjeux de demont
lution à saint-aignan pour transporter
toutes les marchandises et plus
particulièrement tout ce qui
s'appliquait le fer l'acier les prix et
deux côtés du revenant de tout tout ce
qui pouvait être le vin etc etc
aujourd'hui classé l'ouvragé toujours
étanche et assure la continuité du canal
de berry
il pourrait toujours marcher si la
navigation avait encore encore lieu mais
justement c'est c'est grâce à sa qualité
aussi de construction et au fait qu'il
soit aussi je pense périodiquement
entretenu qu'on enlève la végétation qui
peut pousser sur ses bords puisque on
est dans un environnement fortement
végétalisée et il faut quand même éviter
qu'il y ait des arbres qui ce qui se met
dans son dance à ciment
rivera et promeneurs s'approprie
toujours l'épopée de la navigation sur
le canal cela c'est les cordages des des
péniches quand il était tiré tiré par
les cheveux ou les ans nous je sais
pourquoi l'époque où nul est donc le
frottement des cordes
parce que quand tu es tourner là-bas la
péniche était là bas donc ça frottements
les cordages et de l'autre bout pareil
assez joli c'est bien c'est un petit
souvenir un souvenir du passé qui porte
les espoirs d'un tourisme doux et vert
dans ce val de cher c'est très beau ici
c'est c'est extrêmement bucolique sait
on est en pleine nature et on a un
ouvrage d'art qui est quand même
extrêmement élégant un ouvrage en pierre
avec des arches extrêmement harmonieuse
et aussi le fait un petit peu d'avoir de
l'eau sur de l'eau je pense que ses
côtés aussi un petit peu exceptionnelle
et spectaculaire qui fait que les gens
aiment bien venir s'ils se balader
à pied en vélo ou à cheval au bord de
l'eau c'est le tourisme plus vaste
requis utilisera désormais les atouts de
cet ouvrage d'art
[Musique]
alors c'est pas bucolique cet endroit ce
quel endroit
alors on est au bord du canal de berry
ici donc vous êtes julien godon
directeur du pays du val de cher
pourquoi c'est pas le cher alors c'est
pas le cher puisque à cet endroit en
fait un canal a été créé c'est le canal
de berry qui en fait transit depuis
noyers-sur-cher jusque dans le
département du cher donc la rivière cher
a disparu ici alors si j'ai bien compris
cette 19e qui a eu beaucoup d'activité
sur cette infrastructure fluvial
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant dans ce canal alors ce
canal est déclassée en fait depuis
quelques semaines depuis de nombreuses
années l'idée c'est quand même de
pouvoir transiter le long de ce canal
aujourd'hui et notamment avec l'arrivée
de la véloroute coeur de france à vélo
cascade dans cette infrastructure
fluviale qui est adapté à la véloroute
alors ici on est sur les berges du canal
donc ce sont vraiment les supports pour
pouvoir aménager cette future véloroute
plus en aval on est sur le cher canalisé
et là pour le coup on est plus sur des
chemins de halage
l'idée cette véloroute ça va être la
même chose que la loire à vélo ça sera
le pendant de la loire à vélo
effectivement on est sur une véloroute à
vocation touristique vraiment
structurant c'est le pendant
effectivement de la loire à vélo mais
sur un territoire beaucoup plus je
dirais authentique et intimiste on est
vraiment ici au coeur de au coeur de la
france
alors ce qui est bizarre c'est que c'est
le val de cher on dit canal de berry
pourquoi canal de berry parce que
effectivement on rend hommage au duc
jean de berry à l'époque qui
effectivement était commanditaire de la
réalisation de ce canal donc ce n'est
pas la province mais c'est vrai que
canal de berry aujourd'hui peut en fait
faire se rattacher à la province du
berry quand est ce qu'on pourra faire
ses 70 km au bord du chemin on espère la
fin d'année prochaine en 2021
on vous retrouve alors à vie s'il est un
grand plaisir